April 21,
we have to vote
for 11 questions that will not be numbered,
but in alphabetical order,
from a to k.
And this is part of what is called democracy.
direct.
The origin was in ancient Greece,
where plebiscites were organized,
which comes from the denomination of the plebs,
who were the ones who were
below the Patricios
and below the aristocracy.
What citizens are today
is a form of popular consultation,
of direct democracy.
It means plebiscites,
referendums or
recall consultations.
Full visit,
generally on an issue of political relevance,
not necessarily texts,
and the referendum is on legal texts.
This is a worldwide custom.
In the medieval period,
it was also made in the
19 and in the 20th century,
almost all countries of the Western Hemisphere.
Did you know that there are two countries in Latin America?
what more plebiscites
and consultations were held on Monday in Uruguay,
who seems to me to have had 18 or 20 consultations,
and the other Ecuador,
that in the last 46 years we will have 13 consultations
popular.
There are people who question and say it is not necessary.
And I reflect and say,
whether a consultation on cockfighting was necessary,
about casinos,
about bullfighting,
how a popular consultation will not be necessary
on an essential topic,
fundamental,
which distresses us,
that concerns us,
what is the issue of insecurity
and the Role of the Armed Forces.
Consequently,
popular consultation is fully justified